[Musik]
zu viele Menschen zu wenig Geld
Flüchtlingsfrage ungelöst das ist unser
Thema heute Abend liebe Zuschauer sein
Sie ganz herzlich begrüßt an diesem
Donnerstag eine Million Menschen aus der
Ukraine und allein in diesem Jahr schon
mehr als 100.000 Asylbewerber Städte und
Gemeinden sind mit ihren Möglichkeiten
am Ende sie wollen mehr Geld aber auch
weniger Migration gelöst wurde ihr
Problem gestern nicht Bund und Länder
haben bei ihrem Treffen mehr vertagt als
beschlossen zwei unserer Gäste heute
waren gestern dabei und sie treffen auf
diese weiteren Gäste
der niedersächsische Ministerpräsident
Stefan weil
um mit Nuri pur Vorsitzender von Bündnis
90 grüne
der evp-vorsitzende Manfred Weber
die Journalistin Mariam lau
die migrationsexpertin Birgit Glorius
und Heiko Täger von der Deutschen
Polizeigewerkschaft sie sind zu Gast bei
Maybrit
Illner und die begrüßt alle Gäste dieser
Sendung noch mal ausgesprochen herzlich
noch ein Gipfel zur Migration und immer
noch sind die wichtigsten Fragen
ungelöst
der placebo-gipfel ist zu Ende die
Probleme bleiben
eine Milliarde notpflaster zusätzlich
vom Bund das war's der Streit um ein
neues Finanzierungssystem für Länder und
Kommunen geht weiter
erst Ende November soll es Klarheit
geben
nein ich bin nicht zufrieden das ist
eben eine Milliarde für dieses Jahr was
ist nächstes Jahr die Kommunen bauen
jetzt
Unterkünfte sie müssen wissen was wird
wann wie von wem bezahlt warum das bis
November dauern muss ist mir
schleierhaft ehrlich gesagt wir können
nie Anforderungen die wir in unserem
Land haben sagen Asyl ist die
allergrößte wir haben andere Aufgaben
auch noch zu erfüllen das Geld schafft
mir in meinem Landkreis keine Flächen
das Geld schafft mir nicht mehr Personal
was auf dem Markt im Augenblick nicht
akquirieren kann und insoweit ist all
das was weiter in dem Papier steht also
was man jetzt noch vor hat erstmal ja
eine Ankündigung
sagt ein grüner Bürgermeister Stefan
weil ist bei uns er ist der Chef dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die da
gestern tagte und Ministerpräsident von
Niedersachsen weiß eigentlich jeder sie
haben gesagt der Streit mit den Kanzler
weil habe sich gelohnt
wie können das all die Bürgermeister in
dem Land eigentlich anders einschätzen
gemessen an dem was gedroht hat dass wir
nämlich ein Riesenstreit zwischen
Ländern und Bund haben und für die
nächsten Monate nur dieses Bild der
zerrissen hat geboten hätten ich bin
nicht zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis
insgesamt aber wir haben gestern ich sag
mal ein etappenergebnis erzielt eine
Milliarde Euro das ist jetzt auch nicht
nichts und wir haben eine Arbeitsprozess
vereinbart aber ich sag auch wenn am
Ende dieses Prozesses nicht ein wirklich
zufriedenstellendes Ergebnis steht dann
haben wir dasselbe Problem dass wir
gestern knapp vermieden haben meine
Befürchtung ist die Zahlen in diesem
Jahr werden weiter steigen und dann
werden in ein paar Monaten werden wir
uns nicht mehr mit über die Frage
ärztlich unterhalten brauchen wir ein
solches System dass Kommunen wesentlich
stärker unterstützt das wird so sein
seit acht Monaten es ist definitiv nicht
unsere erste Sendung zu dem Thema seit
acht Monaten beklagen sich Bürgermeister
dieses Landes bitterlich haben sie
schlecht für die Kommunen verhandelt
nein wir haben wirklich gefaltet das
kann ich sagen alle 16 Länder wir sind
auch alle in der gleichen Situation wir
sind ja ziemlich dicht dran wir begegnen
täglich BürgermeisterInnen
Bürgermeisterin Behörden und natürlich
natürlich das geht uns allen
gleichermaßen so und vor allen Dingen
wir haben gemeinsam den Eindruck die
übertreiben nicht es ist ja richtig was
gesagt wurde es geht nicht nur ums Geld
es geht beispielsweise auch um die Frage
wo kommen wir überhaupt die Unterkünfte
rein wo kriegen wir das Personal her und
so weiter und so weiter aber was wir im
Moment wirklich vermeiden müssen ist
dass diejenigen die die Hauptplatz zu
tragen haben nämlich die Kommunen dass
die den Eindruck haben im Zweifel werden
sie dann eher alleine gelassen das darf
nicht geschehen und noch zum Verständnis
atmen des System das wollten sie das gab
es in Deutschland dass meint kommen mehr
Flüchtlinge gibt tut es mehr Geld warum
wollte ihr Parteifreund der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz dieses dem
ausgerechnet nicht mehr ja der Bund sagt
er tut doch jetzt schon sehr viel
insbesondere für die Ukraine Flüchtlinge
das stimmt auch aber das ändert ja
nichts an der Situation für die Kommunen
die insbesondere auch die Hauptlast zu
tragen haben was Asylbewerber angeht und
da nähern sich die Zahlen gerade
deutlich an im letzten Jahr hatten wir
die Situation es kommt wesentlich mehr
Menschen aus der Ukraine als es
Asylanträge gibt und inzwischen gleicht
sich das ziemlich stark an und das eine
ist eher stabil und das andere stark
steigend und deswegen wenn nichts
Wesentliches Neues passiert dann werden
wir genau an dieser Stelle in diesem
Jahr ein großes Problem kriegen nach
meiner Einschätzung im Sommer und da
machen sich die Kommunen machen sich die
Bürger die aller Bürgermeister die aller
größten Sorgen und ich habe dir dafür
volles Verständnis und das ist jetzt
erstmal verschoben bis in den Sommer wir
fragen uns gleich was im Sommer und im
November dann eigentlich anders wenn ich
da schlimmer ist und mit pur ist bei uns
einer der zwei Chefs der Grünen
sie haben gesagt man können nicht immer
von Gipfel zu Gipfel hangeln sonst
kriegt man keinen Boden unter die Füße
sie fallen dem Kanzler in den Rücken sie
sind mit diesem Ergebnis nicht
einverstanden Mama wir haben stets
gesagt dass wir glauben dass es zwei
Stränge gibt und es gibt einen sehr sehr
schnellen Strang der man begehen muss
und das ist Hilfe für die Kommunen und
diese Hilfe muss organisatorisch sein
die ist beispielsweise wenn der Bund
immobiliens bereitstellt aber der muss
auch finanziell sein das haben wir immer
zum Ausdruck gebracht und haben in der
Stelle auch ein Distanz in der Koalition
das ist glaube ich mehr als äh so so
ungewöhnlich nicht und ähm es ist
ungewöhnlich ist sie haben ein eigenes
Papier in den eigenen grünen zehn
Punkteplan veröffentlicht warum hat es
keine Einigung mit dem ganzen in dieser
Sache gegeben bevor man sich mit den
Ländern trifft die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der Kanzler
hat eingeladen das ist ein Gipfel das
ist ein absolut gutes Recht dort deine
Vorschläge seine Ideen auf dem Weg zu
bringen und es gibt ja noch
parlamentarisches Verfahren es geht im
Haushaltsverfahren und so weiter und so
fort ich glaube dennoch dass es
notwendig ist gerade für die Kommunen
die so gerade im Stress sind dass das
Planungssicherheit gibt und deshalb
verstehe ich auch das Anlegen vom
Städtetag zu sagen der November ist ein
wenig sehr spät für 24 und deshalb
müssen wir jetzt in den nächsten Wochen
noch miteinander ins Gespräch kommen wie
wir bestätigen wie wir eine Systematik
finden und wie wir den Kommunen
tatsächlich helfen ich teile 100 %, das
ist nicht um Geld geht es ist auch
absolut richtig zu sagen dass die Länder
auch einiges noch leisten müssen es gab
z.B dieses ganze Thema Digitalisierung
auseinanderbehörden was ja eine große
Rolle gespielt hat bei dem Gipfel aber
unter dem Strich wird es ohne dass es
finanzielle Unterstützung gibt für die
Kommunen auch nicht geht und zügig
Mariam lau ist heute bei uns unter
darüber sind wir doppelt froh geschätzte
Kollegin von der Zeit das Ergebnis von
gestern Frau lau ist eigentlich keins
eigentlich nicht wirklich also
jedenfalls was das Geld angeht jetzt
glaube ich dass die Grünen deshalb ein
bisschen ausgeschert sind weil es für
sie vielleicht leichter ist über das
Geld zu reden als über das was da noch
schlimmer hat nämlich die Tatsache dass
wir uns jetzt in vielem politisch dem
annähern was zum Beispiel Horst Seehofer
mal gefordert hat nämlich das an den
Außengrenzen Verfahren stattfinden und
ähm also schon im Koalitionsvertrag
steht ja die Zahl der Flüchtlinge muss
der illegalen
irregulären Migration muss sinken und
das ist glaube ich eigentlich ich weiß
also wir haben es unterschrieben aber
die Frage ist halt wo kommt man da
wirklich dazu und ich glaube eine
Hoffnung ist halt weil wir vorhin über
den November gesprochen haben das bis
zum Herbst etliche der ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge wieder zurückgegangen sind
und dass dadurch für die Kommunen auch
Erleichterung eine Sache vielleicht bei
der Situation der komm und reden über
die Menschen die jetzt schon da sind und
die versorgt werden müssen sind die 1,1
Millionen Ukraine das Problem Frau lau
oder weil die ja jetzt tatsächlich auch
eben in genau eine Infrastruktur eine
städtische oder dörfliche Infrastruktur
kommen also es klingt so schrecklich zu
sagen die sind das Problem es sind halt
sehr viele Mütter mit Kindern die
Schulen brauchen und Kitaplätze brauchen
und so weiter und das alles ist einfach
nicht da da hilft auch das Geld glaube
ich nicht also jedenfalls nicht in
diesem Maße aber es gibt natürlich
einige Dinge wo man den Kommunen schnell
helfen könnte und das ist ein riesen
Testfall für die Grünen wenn man zum
Beispiel sagen würde georgien ist ein
sicheres Herkunftsland
Moldau ist ein sicheres Herkunft da
könnte man sehr schnell ein paar tausend
Leute die in Verfahren sind ohne
irgendeine Aussicht also kaum Aussichten
auf Anerkennung sehr schnell wieder
zurückbringen jetzt haben sie schon
angerissen dass das ein viel größerer
Kosmos ist und ich verspreche dass wir
bei der Größe dieses Kosmos ist auch
noch ankommen werden nochmal zurück zu
den Kommunen das und wie sehr die
Kommunen leiden verfolgen leiden und ja
keine Lösungen finden oder immer wieder
nur behelmsmäßige Lösungen finden
erzählen wir seit acht Monaten warum hat
man das so lange aufgeschoben weil das
Geld alle ist also da bin ich jetzt
ausnahmsweise mal bei Christian Lindner
passiert nicht so oft aber in dem Fall
hat er glaube ich recht also
die Zeiten in denen man Geld auf
Probleme werfen konnte die sind jetzt
einfach vorbei und naja irgendwann wird
man da aber auch eine politische
Würdigung vornehmen müssen und ehrlich
gesagt bei der Thema bei dem Thema
Unterbringung von AsylbewerberInnen etc
da geht es ganz am Ende nicht nur ums
Geld da geht es auch nicht nur um die
reine Unterbringung da geht's auch um
das Klima in dieser Gesellschaft und
deswegen glaube ich es nicht ein Thema
wie jedes andere dass man ich sag mal
mit der normalen fiskalischen Logik sich
anschauen kann es geht um mehr so und
dann sind wir hier aber vielleicht bei
einer nächsten Zeitenwende wenn ich das
gleich zurück fragen darf weil
vielleicht soll und muss es auch eine
Zeitenwende in Bezug auf die Asylpolitik
geben wenn das die Intention des
Bundeskanzlers ist und man könnte es
annehmen wenn man seinen Plan liest dann
ist die Frage warum er das erstmal gegen
die Grünen und auch erstmal gegen die
Bundesländer intoniert hätte er dann
nicht eigentlich klarerweise beides
gemacht nämlich sich mit seiner Ampel ge
schlecht und in Ländern Geld angeboten
um auf jeden Fall auch eine Bereitschaft
zu haben über eine Zukunft in der
Asylpolitik nachzudenken damals könnte
vielleicht auch umgekehrt sein gestern
hat Olaf Scholz die Sicherheit bekommen
dass die Länder weitestgehend seine
Planung im Blick beispielsweise auf die
künftige Gestaltung des
Zuwanderungsrechts teilen das hilft ja
vielleicht auch dem Bundeskanzler ich
weiß es nicht aber da haben wir
tatsächlich sehr schnell auch einen
großen Konsens erzielt denn im Wald ist
es ja so wir können uns natürlich
hingebungsvoll über Geld streiten das
reduziert ja nicht die Zahl der Menschen
die kommen und das lässt sich
tatsächlich am Ende des Tages
wahrscheinlich nur auf der europäischen
Ebene wirklich lösen und ist dort schon
wahnsinnig schwer und das ist wahnsinnig
schwer und deshalb sind wir umso
dankbarer auch Manfred Weber heute bei
uns in der Sendung zu haben und mal
nicht zugeschaltet nach Corona
evp-vorsitzender im Europäischen
Parlament auch Fraktionsvorsitzender
herr Weber sie sind aber auch
niederkranke Niederbayern entschuldigen
Unterfranke und Niederbayern auch ihre
Bürgermeister retournieren eine
wenigstens anstrengende Situation
parteiübergreifend alle miteinander die
Belastungsgrenzen sind erreicht das ist
die das ist de factum übrigens nicht nur
bei uns in Deutschland wir haben das
gleich in die Niederlande in Österreich
in vielen Ländern der Europäischen Union
die attraktive sozusagen Standard sind
für Menschen die die auf der Flucht sind
und der neuen neuen Lebensraum suchen
ich möchte schon beim Geld dazu sagen
wir haben ja wir reden über Steuergeld
und ich glaube die Bürger können
unterstützen und unterstützen aber in
der Breite Geld für Menschen die
beispielsweise aus dem Wahnsinn von
bachmund aus dem Wahnsinn der Ukraine
fliehen da glaube ich sind viele bereit
auch Steuergerät bereitzustellen wenn
man jetzt sicherstellen können dass die
Geld nicht für die genutzt werden eben
kein Bleiberecht haben dann bricht eben
was dann entsteht das Problem in der im
Vollzug und das zweite muss deutlich
sagen auf der europäischen verschiedene
sind natürlich schon viele überrascht
warum Deutschland dann jedem Flüchtling
der kommt gleich hartz-iv-standard gibt
also die Höhe der Erstattung die
Deutschland gewährt ist natürlich
beispiellos innerhalb der Europäischen
Union in der Höhe zahlt es sonst niemand
und das ist natürlich auch für
Deutschland
zusatzproblem weil es attraktiver ist
nach Deutschland
und auch das war eigentlich politischer
Konsens und wir werden auch darüber noch
reden nicht bevor wir nicht auch unseren
fünften Gast vorgestellt haben Birgit
lorius nämlich sie ist
migrationsforscherin an der TU Chemnitz
und kann uns helfen bei der Beantwortung
der Frage wenn es wie gerade gehört um
auch Vertrauen in die Demokratie geht
bei diesem Thema Frau Glorius machen wir
es eben so groß wie es ist
warum und wie wichtig ist es dann dass
gerade in die Kommunen die Arbeit
funktioniert ich würde gerne um die
Frage zu beantworten ein bisschen weiter
sogar noch zurückgehen wir hatten ja
jetzt über die Ukraine gesprochen und
über die jetzige Situation und ich würde
gerne zurückschauen in das Jahr 2015/16
als wir eben schon mal ein kleiner
großen Krise gesprochen hatten 890.000
Asylanträge in diesen zwei Jahren und
Ende 2014 wurden schon Turnhallen belegt
damals und das war damals eine
Ausnahmesituation die Kommunen haben das
sehr engagiert gemeistert es haben sich
unglaublich viele Menschen in der
Bevölkerung engagiert haben helferkreise
gebildet es viele gerade schon hier das
Wort das eben auf der auf der kommunalen
Ebene letztendlich die Demokratie
stattfindet und Gesellschaft auch gelebt
wird und es wurde wirklich sehr
vorbildlich getan und dann sind einige
Jahre ins Land gegangen wo wir sehr
weniger Asylzahlen haben eben auch
bedingt durch entsprechende politische
Änderungen dann kam Corona dann waren
natürlich insgesamt die mobilitätszahlen
sehr niedrig und in diesem Jahr
meines Erachtens verpasst worden sich im
Nachgang dieser Migrationssituation 15
16 mal Gedanken zu machen das zu
evaluieren und Gedanken zu machen wie es
langfristig weitergehen kann stattdessen
wurden eben Unterkünfte wieder
geschlossen zusammengelegt und auch
integrationsinfrastruktur zurückgebaut
wir sind jetzt sicherlich in einer
absoluten Ausnahmesituation trotzdem
ging es ja sehr lange gut im letzten
Jahr und ich denke aber inzwischen ist
tatsächlich so ein kumulativer Punkt der
Überlastung erreicht den man nicht mit
Geld heilen kann aber es ist ein klug so
um Milliarden zu zocken wenn ich das mal
trotzdem das Geld braucht man ja
trotzdem auf jeden Fall und zwar auch in
gesicherter nachhaltigerweise ja also
diesen Begriff dieser atmenden Systeme
finde ich eigentlich ganz treffen
natürlich brauchen dass die Kommunen die
ja eben an ganz vielen Stellen auch
agieren ja die haben ihre
wohnungsproblematik die
Energieproblematik es sind viele der die
2015/16 gekommen sind leben immer noch
in den Gemeinschaftsunterkünften weil
sie keine Wohnung gefunden haben und
dann eben eine hohen Ukrainer die zwar
sehr geräuschlos aufgenommen wurden aber
die ja trotzdem vor Ort sämtliche
Infrastrukturen benötigen wohnen
Gesundheit Kita Schule Beratung und das
ist natürlich eine Riesenlast auf den
kommunalen Schultern auch darüber haben
wir hier in der Sendung schon gesprochen
und hatten Herr weil eine ukrainische
Ärztin zu Gast unter anderem die
insgesamt sechs Monate auf einen
Sprachkurs wartete und insgesamt 11
Monate wartete und es war noch gar nicht
dazu gekommen ihre Approbation überhaupt
anerkannt zu bekommen eine Ärztin aus
der Ukraine die im elften Monat auf die
Anerkennung ihrer abrupation wartete nur
ein ganz kleiner Einschub wenn uns das
nicht mal gelingt wie soll uns denn dann
in Anbetracht der Zahl der Menschen
gelingen tatsächlich eben auch
migrationsvorschriften Fortschritte und
integrationsfortschritte zu machen also
ich verstehe ich hoffe es jedenfalls
wir machen sicherlich in vielen
Bereichen auch noch
alles andere gelingt tatsächlich aber
gut wir stellen sie sagten eben fest
dass die Aufnahme von einer Million
Menschen wesentlich geräuschloser Erfolg
als das 2015/2016 der Fall gewesen ist
wie kommt das sicherlich weil es um eine
andere Gruppe geht es macht einen
Unterschied ob junge alleinstehende
Männern erster Linie kommen oder Frauen
mit Kindern es macht auch einen
Unterschied ob diese Gruppe einen
höheren oder ein niedrigeres
Bildungsniveau hat und zehn Prozent sind
bisher in den arbeitsmarktintegriert ich
würde sagen schon und ich erwarte dass
das in diesem Jahr deutlich mehr wird da
haben wir wir haben einen schlechtere
Situation als 15 16 und eine bessere 15
16 hat mir ein ziemlich entspannten
Wohnungsmarkt das ist definitiv jetzt
nicht der Fall deswegen ist es für die
Kommunen so schwierig Wohnraum
Unterkünfte überhaupt zu organisieren
die bessere Situation ist wir haben
jetzt ein eklatanten Arbeitskräftemangel
und das macht die Aufnahme in den
Arbeitsmarkt dafür geflüchtete Menschen
z.B aus der Ukraine wesentlich leichter
aber ich will das gar nicht klein reden
das ist schwierig genug und dass wir
noch genug besser machen können dass die
stehe ich ihn sofort zu wir müssen nur
schauen wenn wir jetzt den zweiten als
der Zuwanderung nämlich bei den
Asylanträgen wenn der stark wächst in
diesem Jahr dann können wir wirklich in
Probleme fürchte ich und das ist auch
gar nicht mit nationalen Mitteln
tatsächlich zu verhindern dann müssen
wir auf Europa setzen dann sind wir
jetzt genau in diesem größeren Kosmos
die Sparsamkeit hat der Kanzler garniert
mit einer neuen Härte
[Musik]
die fortschrittskoalition auf dem
retro-trepp plötzlich gibt es ein
Revival der alten Gassenhauer
Oldies but Goldies was wir brauchen sind
natürlich genügend abschiebe Haftplätze
und gewahrsamsplätze dass wir uns
bekennen zum Schutz der Außengrenzen der
Europäischen Union notfalls auch mit
zäunenraum heißt Asyl Schnellverfahren
an EU-Außengrenzen
vermehrt Abschiebehaft und verlängerte
ausreisegewahrsam
plus mehr sichere Herkunftsländer von
Georgien bis Tunesien
klingt wie zurück in die Zukunft statt
vorwärts
Revival eine Horst Seehofer schon
Innenpolitik also wo auf wo zwar
Rechtsstaatlichkeit eingeschränkt wird
aber am Ende kein einziges Problem
gelöst wird das wird es nicht geben
Menschlichkeit und humanitäre
Verpflichtungen spielen in der aktuellen
Debatte keine Rolle
stattdessen spricht die Bundesregierung
über Haftlager an den EU-Außengrenzen
und schnellere Abschiebungen das ist
einer sozialdemokratisch geführten
Bundesregierung unwürdig
kann noch kurz nach einer Antwort
überlegen wir fragen Frau lau
das klingt eins zu eins wie eine
Rückkehr zu den Ideen der CSU ja aber
der große Unterschied ist dass die Ampel
sich vorgenommen hat das zu koppeln
tatsächlich also die Verhandlung an den
Außengrenzen der Verfahren an den
Außengrenzen mit Abkommen mit den
Ländern die sie zurücknehmen sollen denn
natürlich also es war glaube ich sehr
geschickt von der bundesinnenministerin
zu sagen wir schließen uns diesen
Vorschlag an der jetzt aus Europa kommt
und die Deutschen wollen raus aus dieser
Sonderrolle ich erinnere noch mal daran
dass 2015 eine grüne
Fraktionsvorsitzende als Rednerpult
gegen und sagte wir sind Weltmeister der
Humanität
die anderen europäischen Länder können
das glaube ich nicht mehr hören von uns
und es war strategisch sehr geschickt
von Frau Feser das jetzt vorzuschlagen
sich diesen Vorschlag anzuschließen aber
natürlich haben wir weder von Italien
noch von Frankreich noch von Spanien
gehört juhu das machen wir jetzt so wir
haben wahnsinnig Lust Aldi die
unwahrscheinlich Unfälle und die ankerze
ankerzentren zu betreiben und uns um die
Fälle zu kümmern die keine Aussicht
haben wenn sie nicht wissen wo sie dann
mit den Leuten hin sollen und deswegen
brauchen wir und das ist glaube ich für
die Grünen genauso schwierig wie die
sicheren Herkunftsländer deswegen
brauchen wir Abkommen nach dem Modell
des
eu-türkei-abkommens das bei den Grünen
keinen guten Ruf hat weil sie immer
sagen da haben wir uns jemandem
ausgeliefert aber die Wahrheit ist ja
das Erdogan viel Millionen
Syrer untergebracht hat und auch über
weite Strecken gut behandelt und zu
diesen Abkommen diesen
Rückführungsabkommen und einer großen
Offensive die angekündigt ist kommen wir
auch noch ich Frage zunächst mal bei dem
EU Abgeordneten und Parlamentarier herr
Weber haben Sie nachvollziehen können
warum unsere Innenministerin denn sie
Feder jetzt von einem Momentum spricht
sich auch in der EU endlich zu
verständigen
wir haben im Moment und das möchte ich
ausdrücklich bestätigen und ich möchte
mich auch durchaus bedanken bei der
Innenministerin weil sie das geht nicht
so weit weil
wir wollen Türen öffnen wir wollen jetzt
ermöglichen dass wir endlich Lösungen
finden auf europäische Ebene ist das
Thema seit 2016 die politische offene
Wunde des Kontinents
Rechtspopulisten rechtsradikale
profitieren in ganz Europa davon wir
brauchen eine Lösung vor der nächsten
Europawahl das sind freue ich mich wenn
sich alle bewegen aber ich bin bei der
Frau lau die entscheidende Botschaft in
Berlin ist man hat in der Gampel
zunächst drei Schritte zurück gemacht
jetzt geht mal wieder eine Stunde da
vorne und beschreibt es als großen
Fortschritte das ist die Wahrnehmung in
Europa weil durch die Politik die in den
letzten eineinhalb Jahren beschrieben
worden ist Deutschland eher wahrgenommen
worden ist dieses
chancengleichstellungsgesetzes der
betrieben wird oder auch die Frage wie
man mit unserem deutschen
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht umgeht und auch
die hohen Sozialstandards die
Deutschland im Vergleich mit anderen
gewährleistet für natürlich dazu dass
die in der Welt der Eindruck entsteht
Deutschland ist weiter aufnahmefähig
bereit will weiter attraktiv sein
sozusagen und deswegen wird in Europa
jetzt die Positionierung der
Bundesregierung sehr positiv
wahrgenommen man kommt in der Realität
an und die Realität heißt und da bin ich
dankbar auch für die Äußerungen die ich
jetzt hier höre ich habe schon im Anfang
des Jahres vom schlafwandel in die
nächste migrationskrise gesprochen ich
habe vorgesprochen wir müssen an der
Außengrenze endlich für Ordnung sorgen
wir brauchen auch Ehrlichkeit dass
manchmal mit Zäune notwendig sein um
Grenzen zu sichern wir brauchen
Entschiedenheit an der Außengrenze die
Bürger erwarten von uns dass wir endlich
sicherstellen dass die die kommen
Flüchtlinge oder Asylbewerber sind und
illegale nicht mehr kommen das ist das
Grundprinzip jeder Diskussion und wenn
sich der Berlin bewegt ist es im Prinzip
willkommen
ist das ein Lob über das sie sich freuen
oder sind sie bei Jessica Rosenthal und
sagen Menschlichkeit und humanitäre
Verpflichtungen spielen in dieser
aktuellen Debatte keine Rolle und das
ist unwürdiglich
der war gut hinterher nicht mehr so aber
der Anfang war gut ähm
wir müssen nur mit drei Aufgaben
gleichzeitig lösen erstens
illegaler Einwanderung soweit wie
möglich verhindern zweitens
Schutzsuchenden soweit wie möglich ihren
Schutz gewähren das ist eine wichtige
Aussage weil mehr als die Hälfte aller
derjenigen zu uns kommen haben ein
Schutzrecht am Ende und drittens haben
wir auch ein Arbeitskräftebedarf das
heißt wir müssen zu einem System von
legaler von uns auch gesellschaftlich
gewollter
Zuwanderung zu kommen und dieser
Dreisprung das ist in der Tat eine
schwierige Aufgabe aber alles drei muss
sein gut ich frage noch mal nach Frau
Rosenthal oder ich könnte auch fragen ob
jetzt ausgerechnet diese
fortschrittskoalition weil in der sie
nicht sind nicht zwingend sind aber mit
dem Herzen als Sozialdemokrat vielleicht
ob ausgerechnet diese sogenannte
fortschrittskoalition auf dem Rückweg
ist nein das kann man nicht sagen denn
das was
kritisiert ist ja in Wahrheit ein großer
Fortschritt darum haben wir in
Deutschland viel zu lange ein Bogen
gemacht uns zu fragen ja auf welche
Weise anderen Menschen zu uns kommen
wenn wir gleichzeitig was wir tun müssen
den illegalen Zugang versperren und
deswegen bin ich auch definitiv nicht
bei der Aussage von Jessica Rosenthal
die ich ansonsten sehr gerne mag aber
definitiv
ausreisegewahrsamen das ist schon eine
ganz schöne Liste die klingt anders als
nach Menschlichkeit ja aber Realität
haben Zuwanderung tatsächlich auch
effektiv verhindern dann werden wir gar
nicht vermeiden können dass auch
diejenigen die zu uns kommen können und
zu uns kommen dürfen weil sie nämlich
schon suchen sind und weil sie
Schutzrechte haben dass die auch fair
behandelt werden gerade wenn wir das
eine wollen dürfen wir das aber nicht
bleiben lassen
europäischen Ebene die Gesetze werden
bei uns im Europäischen Parlament
entschieden und da haben wir nach wie
vor eine grüne Fraktion und das klar zu
sagen die diese Woche zum Beispiel die
Unterstützung für frontext verweigert
hat also grüne hier sind eventuell am
Weg auch ihre Aussagen zu akzeptieren
das war Aufnahmezentren und Außengrenze
brauchen das war schnell Verfahren
durchführen müssen das war Modell
entscheiden müssen hat jemand der
Bleibeperspektive oder nicht und
natürlich mit Solidarität verbinden
europa muss solidarisch darauf antworten
aber die europäischen Grünen die ja auch
gewählt werden in Deutschland verweigern
das nach wie vor sieht Träumen nach wie
vor eine Welt die es nicht gibt wir
müssen an der Außengrenze der Realität
mit den Schleppern sehen wir müssen die
Realität mit dem Mafia sehen wir müssen
sehen dass man Nachbarn haben die es
nicht immer gut mit mir meinen ich will
dass wir Tunesien Abkommen hinkriegen
aber der Partner ist ja schwieriger das
muss man ganz realistisch sehen also wir
haben viele Herausforderungen und
deswegen kann ich nur sagen die
Ampelkoalition kommt mit diesen
Äußerungen jetzt langsam in der Realität
an und da wo hast Seehofer vor zwei
Jahren okay aber trotzdem werden sie
werden wir teilen oder nicht teilen vor
lauter das ist auch ein bisschen
überraschend für den Bürger ist dass
sich der Bundeskanzler der plötzlich
diesen Sheriffstern an andere wäre
heftet und jetzt in diese Ampel für eine
härtere regierte
oder hat man so viel Angst vor den
Wahlen kann ja auch ein Grund sein also
Angst spielt auf jeden Fall eine Rolle
weil ja jedem klar ist wie was welches
verhätzungspotenzial in diesem Thema
steckt aber ich glaube wir haben eben
immer noch eine Gesellschaft die in
ihrer
überwältigenden Mehrheit einfach beides
will es muss klar sein wer kommt es muss
klar sein dass wir eine Kontrolle haben
und ich glaube die der Unmut innerhalb
Europas richtete sich auch eben gegen
eine Regierung Merkel die gesagt hat man
kann Grenzen nicht kontrollieren
wenn wir das und das tun ist das nicht
mehr mein Land und so weiter das hat
glaube ich in Europa auch schon für
einigen Unmut gesagt und also ich glaube
dass das total im Konsens liegt jetzt zu
sagen wir die Zahlen müssen runter
okay wir sind bei omidori pur und zwar
endlich sie haben bisher von sich aus
Herrn Rüppurr Herrn Weber überhaupt noch
nicht widersprochen ich lese jetzt noch
mal sie warten auf die hier ist sie
Asylzentren in Europa und in Europa und
in Deutschland schnell Verfahren
ausreisegewahrsam erhoben erhöhen
Grenzkontrollen die Grünen machen das
alles mitzunehmen
erstens das darf bei den Kommunen und
der Belastung nicht unerwähnt bleiben
wenn ich mir den Leuten rede und auch
wiederum parteiübergreift
Sozialdemokraten CSU Lehrer Leute vom
von den Grünen die sagen relativ
deutlich und klar die Überforderung und
ganz viele leisten der unglaubliche so
Kriege und ganz viele sind es ist ja
nicht so dass alles am zerstin ist aber
die sagen die Überforderung kommt nicht
in erster Linie über die Zahl der Leute
sondern über die Dauer der der Aufgabe
und und dass sie einfach gar nicht
aufhört und das ist das was sie so
unglaublich
beschäftigt und deshalb ist ja die Frage
der Planbarkeit bei den Finanzen und so
zentral zweitens verstehen immer noch
nicht warum sich die Ampel und
Entschuldigung herr Scholz in seinem
Gipfel jetzt vertagen musste mit den
Ministerpräsidenten
es gibt nicht unbegrenzt Geld das ist
überhaupt keine Frage und das ist
natürlich eine Frage wenn man die
Prioritäten setzt wir haben die
gemeinsamen Ziele und die Frage wie wir
dahin kommen da gibt es halt Differenzen
und über die reden wir miteinander das
ist glaube ich das normalste was ist so
gibt und ich erinnere mich noch mal in
diesem Tisch gesessen habe aber ganz
anders diskutiert haben miteinander
innerhalb Koalition also dieses System
sich auch nicht so viel ausgetauscht wie
kehren zurück zu den Veränderungen die
es in der Asylpolitik geben soll ich
frage noch mal wir möchten Sie dass das
so kommt ist das mit den Grünen okay wir
wollen Humanität und Ordnung wir wollen
dass wir wollen dass das Recht 2018
aber das was er gemacht hat weil er
anscheinend anders und wir wollen dass
es rechts passiert ist und wir wollen
dass es funktioniert 2015 gab es eine
bestimmte Kilometerzahl den Zäunen in
Europa heute haben wir das Sechsfache
das kann man den ganzen Tag überzeugen
reden und damit die illusions hören dass
das es dann am Ende tatsächlich dazu
führt dass wir nicht ähnliche
Diskussionen wie 2015 aber jetzt haben
wir ein Revival also stelle ich die
Frage sind wir jetzt auf dem richtigen
Weg und ich finde das man das
diskutieren muss die Frage der
Machbarkeit
also ich kann dir mal
zitieren einmal zuhören
wir müssen an der europäischen Grenze
wissen wer die EU betritt wo die
Menschen herkommen und wie hoch die
bleibe Wahrscheinlichkeit ist
so das registriert und das ist das
Screen beispielsweise das ist Carmen
Sense das ist im Europaparlament
verabschiedet worden
wenn ich jetzt mal aussprechen darf herr
Weber hat ja den Tagesbefehl von Söder
einmal am Tag über die Grünen zu reden
dazu gehört dann auch das einfach mal
drüber gesprochen und was sie da machen
und ich kann Ihnen sagen dass das ist
gar nicht das Thema das Thema ist wie
wir diese die die die Verfahren so
ordnen dass am Ende des Tages die Leute
die Schutz brauchen Schutz bekommen und
die Staaten die größte Belastung haben
nicht überfordert sind und da kann ich
nur wiedergeben die europäische Lösung
die 25 sind folgende plötzlich ganz laut
und welche mit beschrieben worden ist
ist auch deshalb nicht gekommen weil die
Merkel Regierung die Jahre vorher genau
diese Verteilungsfragen in der EU
verweigert hat und als Deutschland
plötzlich dran war wollten auf einmal
alle jetzt die Verteilung und dann haben
die selben Staaten die vorher das nicht
bekommen haben da gesessen und gesagt
jetzt seid ihr dran und das ist doch
nicht so geht es nicht und Sie wissen
und ich glaube darauf kann man sich
einigen Europa funktioniert einfach
nicht dass man Solidarität dann
einfordert wenn man sie braucht sondern
da muss man einfach immer stehen
zueinander
das Konzept der sicheren
Herkunftsstaaten halte ich für extrem
überschätzt das Starten die auf dem Weg
in die Europäische Union sind und dabei
auch noch Fortschritte machen
die Fortschritte machen bei
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und Menschenrechten
komplett anders behandelt werden müssen
ist eine Binsenweisheit und ja das ist
alles überhaupt keine Frage ich würde
nicht grundsätzlich sagen starten die in
die Europäische Union wollen und ein
Kandidatenstatus bekommen müssen man
muss man da sichere Herkunft starten
einstufen weil die Türkei dann zum
Beispiel dazu kommen würde und der Abbau
von Rechtsstaatlichkeit in der Türkei in
den letzten Jahren ist ja mehr als
greifbar sind in der Türkei 4 Millionen
Flüchtlinge untergebracht und wenn man
dann sich hinstellt und sagt weil die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in der Türkei keine
gewährleisten
Koalition gehört von ihrer Fraktion
gehört das ist spannend das ist ja
Afghanistan abschieben wir werden über
solche Fragen diskutieren wenn 4
Millionen Flüchtlinge in der Türkei sind
wie wollen sie dann begründen dass einer
der zurückgeschickt wird nicht dort
ähnlich untergegangen irgendeinen
Gedanken führen
die Flüchtlinge dort zu unterstützen das
ist gut Geld
das bringt wenig kein ja oder nein
sondern das bringt wenig deswegen
auf dem Tisch bringen die ist einfach
nicht bringen der Türkei Deal ist auch
daran gescheiterin
ist daran gescheitert wenn Sie die in
der Türkei mal unterwegs sind und fragen
weil die europäischen Staaten die Tal an
Leuten die im Deal steht dass sie sie
aufnehmen würden nicht aufgenommen haben
und deshalb sind das 4 Millionen Leute
zur Wahrheit gehört dass die vier
Millionen eins zu eins quasi hätten
halbiert werden müssen nach den Deal der
verabschiedet worden ist sind sie jetzt
für alle fordern und 2 Millionen Leute
mehr werden hier gewesen dann müssen sie
das auch noch dazu sagen wenn sie jetzt
plötzlich dem das Wort reden
ohne dass man das zu Ende buchstabiert
für die Bevölkerung ist einfach Sand in
die Augen streuen und das ist keine
Lösung die Lösungen Europäischen
Parlament mit breiter Mehrheit
angenommen worden ist die Grünen die
einzige Position waren demokratische
Bereich deshalb wenn man durch die was
ist notwendig und da Außengrenze muss
man erstmal Menschen retten erster Punkt
ist wir müssen dann schnell prüfen
gibt's Perspektive ja oder nein dafür
sind Zentren notwendig
laufen lassen muss
nur hier sagen aber nicht bei los Honig
darf man es ausführen an der Landgrenze
müssen wir grenzen sichern ein grüner
Minister in Finnland hat einen Vertrag
mit der Firma unterschrieben einen über
500 km langen Zahn noch Russland zu
bauen weil er anders die Grenze nicht
sichern kann und dann müssen wir ein
Screening durchführen da muss man es ist
wichtig weil das die SPD nach wie vor
ablehnt nämlich an der Außengrenze
Fingerabdruck ich möchte
Sicherheitsprüfung mit wem haben was zu
tun und ich möchte wissen ob die
Gesundheitsstandards eingehalten werden
und wenn dann Bleibeperspektive ist dann
brauchen wir die Solidarität das ist das
Paket das verbrauchen um Europa endlich
fit zu machen
weil es Bereitschaft jetzt gibt die
Mädel aus Europäer haben mit der Ukraine
gespielt wir sind auch betroffen heute
ist Tschechien Land ist viel leistet
enorm viel Leistung wir brauchen diese
europäische Lösung
ist und deswegen jetzt haben wir
Momentum lassen sie uns nutzen aber
dafür muss man Verantwortung übernehmen
und ich bleibe dabei die Grünen im
Europäischen Parlament verweigern diese
Verantwortung
weil die Frage jetzt einmal ganz kurz ob
Sie lieber mit Frau Meloni und Herrn
Berlusconi verhandeln als mit den Grünen
das ist jetzt nur eine kleine
rhetorische Frage damit ich noch mal zu
Frau Lorenz interessieren
damit wir einmal mit Frau Glorius noch
was verstehen können jetzt wird wieder
Frau Glorius über ankerzentren geredet
also ankerzentren nicht nur registrieren
das war schon Özdemir Screening
ankerzentren heißt die Menschen vor
Europa zusammen und zu überprüfen ob sie
überhaupt hineinkommen dürfen was soll
diese ankerzentren unterscheiden von den
Lagern in Moria
gar nichts also ich denke das ist genau
das gleiche das ist diese Idee eben
Hotspots einzurichten um Menschen eben
ja an den Grenzen zurückzuhalten ich
verstehe die ganzen Argumente die hier
ausgetauscht wurden insbesondere auch
dieses Notwendigkeit sagen Sicherheit
auch zu gewährleisten eben dadurch dass
Menschen identifiziert werden aber mir
geht die Debatte ein bisschen zu stark
um diese Abschottung Europas wir haben
sehr stark über Realitäten gehört und
über Verantwortung und wenn man das
wieder mal ein bisschen breiter zieht
haben wir eine Welt mit 100 Millionen
geflüchteten die weitaus Mehrheit davon
dieser Verantwortung wird im globalen
Süden geschultert und das ist genau die
Weltregion der wir frei Mobilität nicht
gewähren während wir Europäer sehr
gemütlich ins ländliche Länder der Welt
relativ schnell reisen können und das
wird sehr genau beobachtet es wird in
den Aufnahmeländern in Afrika sehr genau
beobachtet wie die Europäische Union mit
asylthemen umgeht und diesen
Zusammenhang muss man meines Erachtens
viel stärker im Blick behalten ich habe
mit großen Wohlwollen wahrgenommen dass
man versuchen möchte zusammen mit den
geplanten migrationsabkommen eben
wirklich auch auf Augenhöhe mit den
entsprechenden Ländern zu verhandeln und
eben auch Alternative
mobilitätsmöglichkeiten anzubieten wir
dürfen auch nicht vergessen wir haben
über diese Bilder sehen von Menschen die
im Boot sitzen und dann alleinstehende
Männer hören die dann da kommen und so
weiter das sind ja keine
wilden Gesellen die hier schlimme Dinge
tun wollen das sind Menschen die auf dem
Weg sind sich ein besseres Leben
aufzubauen und wir sind eine alternde
Gesellschaft in Europa die
Arbeitsmigration braucht und ich denke
wenn wir das irgendwie in den Griff
kriegen wollen aber die müssen wir diese
beiden Systeme in einen Gleichgewicht
bekommen wir sind wieder bei Herrn Weber
und sagen irgendwie in den Gift kriegen
ist in Europa ja schon eine Zeit äh
versucht worden diese geflüchteten fair
zu verteilen oder sie zurückzuschieben
in ihre Herkunftsländer warum sollen die
Griechen und die Italiener jetzt
eigentlich glauben dass das plötzlich
funktioniert soll an einem Tag X das ist
genau die Frage weil die Realität die
wir heute haben ist dass Deutschland und
Frankreich Italien zugesichert haben
7000 Flüchtlinge freiwillig zu
übernehmen wenn Italien die helfen
öffnet und weil ich auf Italien
angesprochen worden bin Italien rettet
derzeit die italienische Küstenwache
trägt die bei der Rettung im Mittelmeer
sie nehmen sie auf es gibt keinen
gesperrten italienischen Hafen und
gleichzeitig hat Emanuel macron jetzt
Truppen an die Polizeitruppen an die
italienische Grenze geschickt um
sicherzustellen dass keine illegalen
noch in Frankreich kommen Frankreich
macht derzeit also es war dauernd
Italien vorgeworfen haben das ist der
Egoismus den wir derzeit erleben und
auch Deutschland hat wenn zugesagten
7000 gerade 400 übernommen auch
Deutschland war nicht Vertragspflicht
das ist das ist der Fluss den wir haben
in der Europäischen Union deswegen
brauchen wir den Durchbruch und eines
ist auch noch ganz wichtig wir werden
die legale Migration beantworten müssen
wir sind der alt und da konnte nicht
Menschen ehrlich sagen es wird sich
unsere Gesellschaft ändern die
Strukturen werden sich ändern aber in
Afrika wird es nach wie vor Sie haben
die Zahlen gehen und 100 Millionen auf
der ganzen Welt die er Flüchtling sind
es wird trotz unserer
Aufnahmebereitschaft über legalen Weg
zum Arbeitsmarkt nach wie vor Millionen
Menschen geben die trotzdem auf der
Suche nach einem besseren Leben sind das
heißt das Migrationsproblem wird damit
mit legaler Zuwanderung nicht lösbar
sein wir brauchen die Ehrlichkeit dazu
an der Außengrenze Recht und Ordnung
durchsetzen müssen und da sind einige
Politiker bereit dazu und andere eben
wir haben gerade in der Griechenland und
Italien gefragt sie haben sich gemeldet
und wollen dazu noch was sagen also jede
kritische Frage hier ist berechtigt und
nur schwer zu beantworten aber die Summe
aller kritischen Fragen ergibt keine
Antwort und das mal sozusagen also man
kann gegen alle Details dieses Konzepts
dieses und jenes einwenden und man kann
den Rahmen auch noch viel größer ziehen
aber wenn wir uns fragen wie kommen wir
eigentlich zu einem System von geregelt
dazu Wanderung und die kommen wir dazu
dass wir die mit Schutzrechten
unterscheiden können für die ohne
Schutzrechte
müssen mein Vorschlag jedenfalls
orientieren wir uns mal an dem was es
gibt auf der Welt das beste
zuwanderungssystem dass ich kenne auf
der Welt ist keiner da wir haben es
natürlich geographisch leichter ist klar
aber vieles von dem was wir jetzt mit
der Bundesregierung gemeinsam
verabschiedet haben und das offenbar ja
auch in der Bundesregierung diskutiert
wird weiß ganz starke Parallelen zu
diesem Konzepte
wir alle und wir kennen zurück zu dem
was wir heute besprechen wollen Herr
Wald also Griechenland und Italien haben
wir schon mal gesagt die haben
eigentlich gerade überhaupt keinen Grund
die Arme hochzureißen und zu sagen hurra
endlich ein ankerzentrum die Situation
haben Sie schon eine Weile und sie ist
dramatisch genug und sie halten die also
da passiert ja auch viel grauenhaftes
was man irgendwie so dann reden wir
jetzt über Rückführungsabkommen mit den
entscheidenden Staaten von denen die
meisten Flüchtlinge kommen also mit
Syrien und Afghanistan können wir diese
Rückführungsabkommen doch überhaupt
nicht abschließen stimmt wobei die Syrer
zu einem ganz ganz hohen Prozentsatz
auch Schutzrechte haben das heißt die
können das Verfahren durchlaufen und
dann können Sie auch zu uns kommen wir
wollen ja nach wie vor zum Grundrecht
auf Asyl stehen und im übrigen glaube
ich hatte Weber schon recht an der
Stelle wenn er darauf Hinweis natürlich
muss da die Europäische Union und die
anderen Mitgliedstaaten müssen wieder
Vertrauen zurückgewinnen gerade auch bei
den Grenzdaten also das ist ein
Riesenprojekt dass man sich da
vorgenommen hat aber andererseits auch
das teile ich was sie sagen die Sch
Straßen waren wahrscheinlich oder der
Druck die waren noch nie überall
gleichmäßig so groß wie derzeit und das
haben wir in den unterschiedlichsten
Ländern aus der unterschiedlichen
Gründen aber wenn es Europa jetzt nicht
schafft wann denn sonst okay wie
hoffnungsfrei sind sie nur dass das
gelingen könnte in Europa und eben auch
mit einem Teil den die Grünen dazu
beitragen es ist notwendig dass wir da
Vorankommen das ist überfällig dass wir
da vorankommen und es ist das heißt am
Ende des Tages
die kann das nur geben wenn es ein
verbindlichen Verteilungsmechanismus
gibt das bleiben sie auf den Leuten
sitzen Verteilungsmechanismus daran wird
es am Ende
Verteilungsmechanismus in Europa wie
soll der gelingen dass man also wie sehr
unfair immer da ist immer noch da
blinden
ist tot es lebe Dublin also wie wird man
organisieren dass es ein faireres
Verteilen der Flüchtlinge in Europa gibt
ich habe es noch nicht verstanden es ist
auch noch nicht durchgeschlagen es gibt
einen Vorschlag der Kommission jedes
Mitgliedsland hat sich verhalten dazu
und dann wird es jetzt Konsultationen
geben mit einem komplett offenen
Ergebnis und Ausgang und es wäre
großartig wenn wir rechts basiert
Humanität und Ordnung in Europa
miteinander zusammenbringen könnten und
es dann Lösung gebe wir werden sehen ob
es gelingt das ist einfach nicht klar so
dann wieder die Rückführungsabkommen das
ist die Alternative also wenn wir
nachgewiesen haben dass jemand nicht
berechtigt in Europa ist und das haben
wir entweder im Schengen Raum oder
außerhalb des Schengen Raums
nachgewiesen dann ist unsere Vorstellung
die Vorstellung der Ampel eine große
rückführungsoffensive noch mal die Frage
Rückführungen würden am meisten Sinn
machen in die Länder aus denen die
meisten Flüchtlinge kommen aber in die
werden wir nie abschieben können weil
sie bis heute
dramatische Diktatoren an der Spitze
haben wenn ich die Zahlen jetzt mal ein
bisschen abrunde wir haben ungefähr 300
1000 ausreisepflichtige in diesem Land
von denen sind gibt es
ausreisehindernisse verschiedenster Art
und wir haben jetzt einen Aufenthalts
einen Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz gemacht
so heißt das und da geht es darum dass
die Leute die in Kettenduldung sind die
Kinder schon in die Schulen gehen längst
dass jeder auch rauskommen wir sind dann
ungefähr bei 50.000 Leuten wenn wir
diese 50.000 LeuTe uns angucken dann
geht es ja eben nicht um die Syrer weil
die haben ja eine sehr hohe schutzquote
beispielsweise da geht es darum dass wir
mit Staaten zu tun haben ihre Leute
nicht zurücknehmen und deshalb hat die
Bundesregierung jetzt einen Beauftragten
der jetzt herumgeht und mit diesen
Staaten spricht und hofft genau das was
Sie beschrieben haben nämlich
migrationsabkommen bei dem es nicht nur
darum geht dass er Leute zurückgeführt
werden sollen das ist auch darum geht
dass wir auch Leute auch anwerben die
wir brauchen
ist jetzt auf dem Weg diese diese diese
ist
Innenministerium angesiedelt und man
soll jetzt diese
rückführungs-abkommen auf dem Weg
bringen wir Patienten in unterstützen
schauen wo die Reise hingeht okay
nochmal die Frage Einsatz nur das wird
nicht funktionieren darüber und da sind
wir jetzt wieder bei Herrn Söder dass
man sagt wir geben euch entweder ihr
nehmt eure Leute zurück oder euch für
die Entwicklungshilfe gekürzt im
zentralen muss doch sein der erste
Gedanke muss doch sein alles dafür zu
tun damit die Leute sich nicht auf den
Weg machen müssen und wenn wir jetzt
grundsätzlich einfach sagen wir werden
dafür sorgen dass sie kein Geld kriegt
frage ich mich nicht ob das nicht auch
im Motor ist und ein Treiber ist damit
sich die Leute auf dem Weg machen die
Lehre von 14 15 ist doch als die Gelder
für das Welternährungsprogramm
gestrichen wurden in den Lagern und
Syrien herum haben die Leute kein kein
nichts mehr zu essen bekommen also haben
sie ihre Kinder geschnappt sind
losgegangen und da sollten wir nicht
mehr wieder hingehen dass wir
weiterhelfen wollen eine entscheidende
Punkt ist doch ob wir es Europäer
vielleicht gemeinsames gut wenn
Deutschland ist versucht aber wenn
Europa gemeinsam mit afrikanischen
Staaten mit äh mit Partner in Asien
übrigens auch aus Südamerika kann man
nach Europa viele Menschen obwohl da als
Europäer auftreten und sorgen zum
Beispiel ja wenn ihr wenn ihr nicht
kooperiert dann wird es halt weniger
Zukunft zum Binnenmarkt geben
wirtschaftliche Argumente dieser
Kontinente stark dieser Kontinent ist
groß also die Frage nicht nur der nette
zu sein der Welt sondern auch der sein
der am Tisch hat und sagt bitte ist ein
abgelehnte Staatsbürger aus deinem Land
nimm sie zurück diese Härte diese diese
Entschiedenheit und dann die Tools dafür
zu verwenden die wir haben eben
Wirtschaft auch die Visapolitik die wir
haben führen legalen zuwanderungsbereich
oder auch und da bin ich beim Markus
Söder auch die Überlegung
Entwicklungshilfe warum nicht die
höchste überhaupt zu nutzen um er auch
Kooperation einzufordern wir dürfen
partnerschaftlich müssen
partnerschaftliche Aufträgen aber wir
sollten nicht naiv auftreten also Wetter
draußen bleiben
aber ich habe jetzt heute bei den
Aufnahmezentren
Aufnahmezentren höre ich ja irgendwie
schon aber so nett bei der Frage
Aufnahme bei der Frage Rückführung ja
aber so nett und so werde ich ja immer
nur
zu gehen und wir brauchen
Zahlen endlich Entschiedenheit und das
sind die Grünen leider die die das nicht
passieren ist auch noch ein wichtiger
Gedanke und wir fragen trotzdem noch mal
diese Frage was entlastet und wie
entlastet es die Kommunen Frau lau jetzt
zu sagen wir sind übrigens härter in
unserer Asylpolitik wir möchten
Rückführungsabkommen jetzt auf Augenhöhe
schließen mit den und den Ländern also
Marokko Tunesien Georgien wollte auch
you name it und dann sind das aber gar
nicht die Länder aus denen die meisten
Flüchtlinge kommen das verstehen doch
die Leute beim dritten na ja aber das
führt uns wieder zurück zum EU Türkei
Abkommen und wenn wir da jetzt einen
neuen Präsidenten hätten was ja wirklich
eine Revolution wäre dann braucht der
natürlich sehr sehr schnell unsere Hilfe
und die kann ja eigentlich nur lauten
wir bieten euch
weiß ich nicht so und so viele
Visafreiheit und so weiter im Gegenzug
nehmt ihr jeden der
illegal hierher kommt zurück also das
heißt die dieses auf Augenhöhe dieser
Rückführungsabkommen hängt einfach damit
zusammen dass wir irgendwelche echten
Interessen also wir sagen nicht einfach
ihr kriegt dann kein Geld mehr sondern
die müssen irgendein Interesse haben wir
nehmen so und so viele Leute die hier
Ausbildungen machen und so weiter es
muss es muss ein richtiger Handel sein
und ich glaube also alles was jetzt
irgendwie davon ausgeht wir brauchen
einen neuen verteilen möchte Mechanismus
vergessen wird nicht passieren es wird
nur also man hat denn es wird Methoden
der Solidarität geben müssen weil sonst
so viele Staaten nicht mitmachen
das beispielsweise Land wie Tschechien
das damals in der Krise zu 15 16 in der
großen migrationskrise gesagt hat wir
nehmen überhaupt keinen auf ist heute
Tschechien eines der Länder dieser
aufgrund der Ukraine zahlen genau zu den
vorderzahl zu den meisten Aufnahme
Ländern gehört also die Zahlen sind
europaweit gar nicht so dramatisch
unterschiedlich die Kosten sind ein
bisschen unterschiedlich aufgrund der
Sozialstandards das macht dann
Unterschied also wir leisten als
Europäer und das ist vielleicht auch das
schöne wenn man das nochmal ins
Bewusstsein bringt wir haben als
deutsche beispielsweise auch als
Europäer im großen Jugoslawienkrieg in
den 90er Jahren Millionen aufgenommen
wir haben in der Syrien Krise 3
Millionen aufgenommen als Europäer
vielleicht nicht 100% so koordiniert
über das wollten wir haben jetzt 8
Millionen Ukraine in der Spitze gehabt
das heißt dieser Kontinent leistet
verdammt viele unsere Kommunen das ist
die schöne das war immer wieder
unterstreichen sollte aber es bleibt am
Ende nur die Frage haben wirklich
bleiben
die neue Realität wird sein dass die
Menschen die noch nicht wissen ob sie
bleiben dürfen eben nicht mehr in den
Gemeinden sitzen sondern in irgendeinem
auffangen Lager und in einem größeren
Auffanglager Monate lang vor sich hin
schmoren und darauf warten wie wir
hoffentlich zügig herausfinden ob sie
dürfen oder nicht ist das jetzt die neue
Realität das ist jedenfalls der Plan
aber nicht monatelang sondern sehr
schnell und anders kann es auch nicht
funktionieren sie haben völlig ich sag
noch mal sie haben völlig recht mit all
diesen kritischen Fragen weil der muss
in vielen erst noch da Nachweis
geliefert werden aber wenn wir mal
umgekehrt kommen nicht von der nächsten
im nächsten bedenken das wären sondern
von dem Ziel dass wir verfolgen dann
finde ich es richtig denn wir wissen aus
jahrzehntelanger Erfahrung wenn Menschen
erstmal bei uns sind und beispielsweise
unklar sind wo sie herkommen dann
scheitern wir sehr schnell mit unseren
Möglichkeiten die wir haben
jetzt
zu spät der springende Punkt für mich
ist wir haben einen völlig neuen Akzent
weil wir wesentlich cleverer im Bereich
der internationalen Politik jetzt
antreten als das 15 16 der Fall gewesen
ist und seitdem die Europa internen
Fragen die sind eigentlich dieselben
geblieben nur dass wir da keine
Fortschritte gemacht haben der einzige
Fortschritt das klingt jetzt zynisch
besteht darin dass inzwischen alle den
gleichen Druck haben alle das gleiche
Probleme haben und das politische Pendel
eher in Richtung
Abschottung und
erschwernismarschiert ist was auch heißt
dass wir nicht mehr über Kontrollen
Grenzkontrollen an den Außengrenzen
Europas reden sondern auch wieder
vermehrt über Grenzkontrollen im Innen
und das müssen wir jetzt auch unbedingt
noch Fragen ist das etwas was die Ampel
ich frage grün und die SPD ist das etwas
vor dieser verkündet das schon das ist
Grenzkontrollen innerhalb Europas gibt
wo die Grünen nicken und sagen ja da
sind wir dabei
und es braucht ganz besondere
damit es passiert
das bedeutet dass es beispielsweise in
der Pandemie Situation gab wo die wo die
Grenzen geschlossen worden sind dafür
gibt es einen Rechtsgrundlage und dafür
muss es auch eine große Härte geben der
gesamte Sinn von von der Kontrolle nicht
der gesamte sind aber ein zentraler Sinn
der der Grenzkontrollen die notwendig
sind außerhalb ist ja auch damit wir
einen Raum von Freiheit und
Freizügigkeit in Europa haben können und
dementsprechend ist
wird obwohl es eigentlich der der Satz
ist ja überall zitiert eigentlich wollen
wir das nicht aber es wird auch Grenzen
und Grenzkontrollen innerhalb Europas
geben das ist doch jetzt auch schon der
Fall natürlich auf die eine oder andere
Weise und Lage abhängig aber wir haben
heute schon im Verhältnis zu Österreich
das und zwar seit etlichen Jahren
wir wissen dass an der polnischen Grenze
jedes Jahr tausende von Menschen
aufgegriffen werden die werden jetzt
nicht direkt bei der Grenzkontrolle aber
sondern eher im Hinterland dann
aufgegriffen also das halte ich für
absolut richtig dass wir sagen wir
wollen die illegale Zuwanderung
konsequent auch versuchen so niedrig wie
irgend möglich zu halten da müssen wir
kein schlechtes Gewissen haben wenn es
umgekehrt dazu dient dass diejenigen die
ein Schutzrecht haben auch wirklich das
in Anspruch nehmen können das sind
Anspruch nehmen können und umso
dankbarer sind wir das Heiko teggers
heute bei uns ist er ist Vorsitzender
der Bundespolizei Gewerkschaft und auf
dem Spielbein ist er auch noch
stellvertretende Chef der Deutschen
Polizeigewerkschaft hätte gern sie
müssen uns helfen bei der Beantwortung
der Frage was sie bisher eigentlich als
Bundespolizei an den Grenzen in Europa
kontrollieren dürfen also beispielsweise
an der
deutsch-österreichischen Grenze und was
sie nicht dürfen denn darüber hat es ja
auch in dieser Zeit
16 bis 18 eine große Auseinandersetzung
in der CDU zwischen merkel und Seehofer
gegeben beispielsweise was dürfen sie ja
also wir zwei Möglichkeiten die ganze
dazu kontrollieren oder zur überwachen
das sind die beiden Möglichkeiten eine
Überwachung der ganze Erfolg in Form der
Schleierfahndung das ist ein geregelt in
ein paar Graphen im bundespolizeigesetz
das dient der Gefahrenabwehr und wir
haben die zweite Möglichkeit der
Grenzkontrollen darüber reden wir ja
jetzt das wiederum gibt der
Bundespolizei die Möglichkeit auch
Maßnahmen nach dem Aufenthaltsrecht zu
treffen nämlich eine Zurückweisung oder
eine Zurückschiebung direkt an der
binnengrenze nach Österreich dürfen wir
das nach Tschechien beispielsweise nicht
also jeder der nicht Gefahr laufen
möchte von der Bundespolizei
zurückgewiesen zu werden an der Grenze
der geht eben um Passau um den
Grenzstein rum und kommt tschechischen
Seite nach Deutschland und dann ist uns
diese Befugnis genommen das ist eben
genau der Punkt den ich auch schon seit
längerem kritisiere im übrigen wie Frau
Ministerin auch schon letztes Jahr im
September schriftlich darauf hingewiesen
hat das hier dringend dran gearbeitet
werden muss wenn wir tatsächlich
Anlastung schaffen wollen für Länder und
Kommune müssen wir begrenzen zunächst
mal bevor wir uns Gedanken machen wie
wir in Zukunft mit denjenigen umgehen
hier sind okay das heißt sie plädieren
eigentlich nicht schöne Grenzkontrolle
sondern für einen Grenzschutz und
bräuchten finden den Gedanken richtig
das ist das wie Frau Faser sagt im
Inneren Europas geben muss weil unsere
Grenzkontrollen an den Außengrenzen
Europas nicht ausreichen auch aus ihrer
Sicht also im Schengenraum verlassen wir
uns ja als schenkstaaten auf die
Grenzkontrollen der Staaten mit den
Außengrenzen ja das heißt also rein
theoretisch dürfte in an der deutschen
österreichischen Grenze niemand
Auftauchen der nicht schon von
irgendeinem Start registriert ist leider
tauchen dort immer mehr Menschen auf die
noch in keinem europäischen Staat
registriert sind und dann sind die
Grenzkontrollen die wir zu Österreich
machen durchaus legitim weil wir haben
Menschen die stellen keine Kraft wir
haben Menschen die haben schon in einem
anderen Land Schutz gefunden wir haben
Menschen die kommen aus sicheren
Herkunftsstaaten oder Menschen die
bereits abgeschoben worden sind mit
einer Wiedereinreise Sperre belegt sind
die dürfen wir dann auch an dieser
Grenze zurückweisen das dürfen wir
natürlich tschechischen Grenze und einer
polnischen Grenze derzeit nicht und
deshalb begrüße ich es ausdrücklich wenn
frau Ministerin jetzt endlich darüber
nachdenkt diese Grenzkontrollen nach dem
österreichischen Modell auch an der
Grenze zu Tschechien zu Polen und zur
Schweiz vor allem auch mal einzuführen
sie muss ja sich nicht mal genehmigen
lassen es ist dem Nationalstaat
vorbehalten die nur anzumelden
Frankreich er hat ja jetzt gebraucht
davon gemacht im übrigen das witzige
nicht nur an der Grenze zu Italien
sondern auch an der Grenze zu
Deutschland
interessant und wir haben die Zaun
müssen wir noch thematisieren die FDP
waren nun mit dem Gedanken dabei
Christian Lindner haben wir ganz zu
Beginn der Sendung damit zitiert dass
auch Zäune möglich sein würden was
helfen die aus ihrer Sicht also
technische Grenzsicherung die immer in
der Kanalisation das klingt jetzt das
klingt jetzt ein bisschen abstrakt aber
wenn sie jetzt in Grenzabschnitt haben
immer mehr Landgrenze das ist ja sowieso
die einzige Möglichkeit mit Technik eine
ganze zu überwachen dann kanalisieren
sie sozusagen die die ankommenden auf
bestimmte Grenzübergänge und haben es
leichter zu kontrollieren wenn personell
nicht möglich ist eine Grenze die
beispielsweise zwischen Polen und
Weißrussland damit mitten durch die
Wälder verläuft die behinderte von
Kilometern dann bleibt manchmal meistens
nichts anderes übrig als eine technische
Sicherung vorzunehmen Zorn ist das eine
sondern
Drohnen da gibt's also Technik noch und
Löcher die dort eingesetzt werden können
an den EU-Außengrenzen wie gesagt
frontext ist auch noch eine gute
Variante aber jetzt komme ich auch
wieder dazu die Nationalstaaten mit
Außengrenzen müssen Frontex anfordern
viele tun es ja nicht Frontex hat nicht
die Befugnis gegen den Willen eines
Staates wie beispielsweise jetzt Italien
dort im Land tätig zu werden die
Entscheidungen sind am gestrigen Tag
noch keine Entscheidungen gewesen das
ist inkorrekt das sind Vorschläge die
diskutiert und entschieden werden sollen
in diese Richtung möchte die Ampel gerne
die Migrationspolitik und Asylpolitik
verändern das ist in ihren Augen
tatsächlich ein großer move oder liest
es sich nicht so es liest sich gut aber
mit Geld und guten Worten werden wir die
Situation nicht in den Griff bekommen
ich erwarte jetzt ein zügiges Handeln
also ich erwarte auch die Traute von
Frau Ministerin auf die EU zuzugehen der
EU mitzuteilen wir wir machen
Grenzkontrollen auch eine Grenze
Tschechien damit wir überhaupt erstmal
den den die Migration zum
Migrationsdruck und selber nehmen weil
wenn jetzt erst im Juni den nächsten
Gipfel haben und vielleicht im November
eine Entscheidung treffen dann sind das
genau gerade die Monate wo
erfahrungsgemäß in den letzten Jahren
die Migration der Migrationsdruck auf
Europa in Deutschland immer extrem
zugenommen wir haben jetzt ja schon
Zahlen erreicht die um ein Vielfaches
höher sind als in den Vergleichsmonaten
der Vorjahre das macht mir große Sorge
klasse dass wir sie heute hier haben und
ich marschieren noch mal zurück in die
Runde und sage
nuripur wir sind sie haben abgelehnt
dass es das in im Inneren Europas geben
soll das ist Grenzkontrollen im Inneren
Europas geben soll auch nachdem was Herr
hegert sagt ist es in ihren Augen
unnötig nicht zu bedenken nicht wichtig
also ich habe darauf hingewiesen dass
unter bestimmten extremen Situationen
das möglich sein muss gleichzeitig gibt
es zum Beispiel die Gewerkschaft der
Polizei die heute erklärt die die das
annonsieren von all diesen von all
diesen Kontrollen sei überhaupt gar
nicht leistbar die Bundespolizei hat 1,8
Millionen Überstunden im Jahr allein die
die Polizei den Länder Polizei noch
deutlich mehr natürlich und gleichzeitig
fehlt ein ausrüstungswelt aneinander
gescheiten Fahrzeugen und so weiter und
so fort und dementsprechend ist es der
Menschen die man versucht irgendwie zu
kontrollieren ergeben allein einen
Treffer in der digitalen Datei
von den weil es geht nicht um um den
Grenzverlauf es geht auch deutlich mehr
dahinter es gibt mobile Kontrollen
beispielsweise die man machen kann die
ist an anderen Stellen gibt die die
wunderbar funktioniert und die Frage ist
warum man die Polizei so in der Form
belasten muss wenn es nicht effektivere
Wege gibt die ja jetzt schon laufen die
man vielleicht auch an der einen oder
anderen Stelle intensivieren kann
deutsche Kontrolle Richtung Polen und
Tschechien mal sich gegenwärtig ich
komme übrigens Niederbayern aus der
Grenze zu Tschechien da würde ich sagen
wünschen sich nur ganz wenige Bürger
wieder Grenzkontrollen sind deutlich zu
sagen und es werden auch im Sommer viele
im Stau stehen müssen in Urlaub fahren
Richtung Kroatien was soll das hier sind
wer Versagen von europäische Politik von
nat Politik wenn man Grenzkontrollen
brauchen interessant die Frage ist ich
bin Europa Politiker ich glaube es
schenken dieser erfüllen eines großen
Traums deswegen werde ich alles tun und
es zur verteidigen die praktische ich
stelle mir ganz praktische Frage die
deutsche Bundespolizei will vielleicht
jetzt kontrollierender dann der
tschechischen Grenze wir kontrollieren
bereits an der österreichischen die
Österreicher kontrollieren Richtung
Slowenien das Slowenien wollen
kontrollieren dann Richtung Kroatien
wenn man all diese Beamten über die
diskutieren mal zusammen nehmen und an
die griechische türkische Grenze
schicken und gemeinsam diese Grenze
sichern wenn Mama gemeinsam
Verantwortung und Außengrenze übernehmen
oder ich sage Ihnen die deutsche
Bundesregierung hat derzeit noch keine
zusatziniente bereitgestellt um frontext
zu unterstützen das ist die Aufgabe
unserer Zeit unsere gemeinsame
Außengrenze zu sichern deswegen ganz
toll aber das klappt ja nur dann wenn
wir tatsächlich eine europäischen
Außengrenze einfunktionierendes System
und das haben wir doch nicht deswegen
sind wir auch in der Situation und ich
kann jede Regierung verstehen nicht nur
die deutsche die zugespitzen Situation
als ein letztes Mittel tatsächlich dazu
greift von gestern und unser Beschluss
immer wieder das Wort Lage abhängig
benutzt jeder von uns weiß dass das ein
ganz hoher Wert ist dass wir durch
Schengen überall grenzenlos sind in
Europa aber wenn es nicht funktioniert
dann wird keine Regierung in Europa das
auf Dauer durchhalten es ist wenn Sie so
wollen gutes Argument dafür dass Europa
insgesamt jetzt den großen Schritt zu
einem wirklich vernünftigen gemeinsamen
Systeme denn ansonsten werden wir immer
wieder bei diesen insel-lösungen landen
kurze Blick war gewünscht
Politiker die den die den Bürgern
versprechen dass es zügig spürbar
geringere Migration Zuwanderung nach
Deutschland geben wird sind die ehrlich
sie spielen mit dem Feuer
weil man damit dann die verschiedenen
Migrantengruppen in einen Topf wirft und
damit irgendwie alle pauschal
illegalisiert mit so einem Ausdruck
also das heißt sie spielen mit dem Feuer